tonight my brand new nationwide
restaurant competition kicks off with
one of the world's favorite cuisines
it's Italian and it promises to be an
incredible battle between two very
different but equally stunning Italian
restaurants
I'm always lovely telling food and that
is best it winning managers transform
simple fresh ingredients into
extraordinary dishes packed full of
flavor
Manvi onion please actually thank you
the italians take their cooking and
ingredients very very seriously and
they're fiercely competitive love that
passion you sent in a huge number of
italian nominations the two fighting for
a place in the semi-finals of this
nationwide competition are both
exceptional casimir from Bristol versus
Manila from London we're going to see
broad young talent from the West Country
taking on a highly experienced chef in
the capital what a war you win it that's
what we're for kazimierz cutting-edge
Italian food will battle it out with
Meniere's authentic rustic dishes -
ambitious young culinary alchemist will
challenge a Sicilian gastronomic
Godfather if you mess up you're gonna
get it I mean you went in for the high
jump with me the sky's the limit
you just want to move forward and gets
it hopping again but who will come out
on top
hopefully you don't mean it mistakes
bring it on what we do I'm going to push
both easy Italian contenders the
breaking point with three daunting
challenges I intend to test some of the
absolute limit because there can only be
one winner the first of my two brilliant
Italian competitors is Manila a truly
exceptional restaurant that fought its
way through thousands of nominations
Manila named after Sicilian almond is
won by 45 year-old Santino who cooks
hearty authentic food inspired by the
love of his birthplace Sicily my cooking
it is all about simplicity it's about
taking as few ingredients as possible
and making sure that the quality of
those ingredients shine he spent years
as a head chef of someone London's top
restaurants before opening Manila a year
ago they quickly gained the law
following his face freeze cessation I
mean that man cooks from the heart
just quit please Bob Santino is fiery
and passionate demanding nothing less
than perfection from always kitchen
staff what the [ __ ] is that doing in
there yeah and these front of house
managers Angelo and Rocco if you've
messed up you're gonna get I mean you
went in for the hi job with me I'm very
competitive person I go out to win I
don't like to lose I won't even guest
anybody's in the country no doubt I love
Santino's competitive spirit and he's
gonna need every ounce of it to handle
my first pressure test because my 30
hand-picked guests are about to arrive
and order all at the same time if every
restaurants worst nightmare when's the
last time we did 30 killers about that
we can do this we can do this okay good
I love that level of confidence your new
restaurants absolutely on the blog a lot
to prove so I'll be watching everything
I'll be like a hawk over a dining room
Rocco and here in the kitchen as well
I'm giving menudo just two hours to
produce the best meal these thirty
customers have ever eaten to your
customers brows and more portly don't
let yourselves down yeah look say like I
see Santino's restaurant is packed I'm
going to push the kitchen in the front
of house to the limit and in the process
give them a chance to shine every
service is war
what's a wall you win it that's what
we're here for